you've been canceled on a small scale a
few times let's not I'm sure it didn't
feel small actually it wasn't small I'm
trying to minimize
uh did that did that psychologically
hurt you yeah it was tough I mean in the
moment you don't know what's going on
but I would like to thank a certain CEO
of a certain well-known company
and he sent me
basically like uh a step-by-step manual
uh and uh does it involve mushrooms no
no and uh and he was right
you know the storm passed and life went
on is it uh I don't know if you can
share the the list of steps but is the
fundamental core ideas that just life
goes on
the the core fundamental idea is like
you need to be willing
and able to apologize
for what is in your control but not for
other people's mistakes
your mistakes yes and if you feel like
there's something then you should take
accountability of that
but to apologize for somebody else for
something that they want to hear
isn't going to solve anything
yeah there's something about apologies
if you do them they should be authentic
to what you actually want to say versus
what somebody else needs to wants to
hear
otherwise it doesn't ring true yeah and
people can see through that and people
can see through it and also what people
see through is not just the fact that
you know your apology was somewhat
Hollow but also that this entire
majority of people now walked away the
mob was like okay thanks
yeah and then people are like
also you didn't care at all this is like
and so then it reflects more broadly on
them